this morning china is battling its worst
outbreak of coronavirus infections it
has seen
in months as it marks one year since
covet 19
forced the city of wuhan into an
unprecedented lockdown
the city of 11 million people was
effectively shut down for a sars-like
virus
that at the time did not have a name cbs
news was the first
international broadcaster in wuhan as
people started dying from covet
raymie and ancincio and his team are
back on the ground with the progress
and the setbacks of the past year
one year since his father died from
kovid
janghai still refuses to pick up his
ashes
this is as close as he'll allow himself
to the funeral home
his personal protest as he sues wuhan
for silencing early warnings
their cover-up is murder he says they
should be held accountable
there should be apologies zhang says his
76 year old father might still be alive
if he hadn't brought him in for
unrelated surgery
i feel angry and sad he says more
commoners died than officials
there wasn't equality in death his
father
now part of china's official toll fewer
than 5
000 lost to covin
but across town the government's bigger
narrative is that china
won and made no mistakes this massive
exhibition now praises president xi
jinping
then frontline workers for beating back
kovid
this is wuhan now on this first
anniversary of the lockdown
it's so jarringly normal with people out
and about so different from the reality
in the united states and so different
from many countries around the world
chinese officials say that the
chronovirus might have come from
someplace else you can't rule it out
peter dashik is one of the 14 world
health organization experts
finally allowed into china they landed
last week to find kovid's origin
what's the probability that kovit
originated here in china it's unclear if
china the country is the real source the
original source of the virus
the evidence right now suggests um a
high probability that the the region of
southeast asia
is where this started you know in bats
that's where it originated
says his father's ashes will stay where
they are
until the communist party apologizes
letting people know what really happened
is beneficial for our country and future
he says but for now
lies are everywhere and few will speak
the truth
for cbs this morning saturday raymie
innocencio
wuhan